avec ses bassins et ses rivières
l'Auvergne est souvent qualifiée de
château d'eau de la France mais ces
jours-ci la région a bien du mal à
honorer sa réputation
Alexis Delcourt en est à son premier
chargement de la journée avec son camion
il devrait assurer 5 livraisons son
mandat garantir l'alimentation en eau du
village de Coucouron
[Musique]
depuis juillet la communauté d'environ
800 habitants est à sec ces sources
naturelles sont épuisées qu'au courant
ne sait en fait jamais remise des
sécheresses de l'été dernier en une
journée 60000 litres d'eau venant de
communauté avoisinantes seront livrées
dans le réservoir de la municipalité
c'est important d'avoir de l'eau on s'en
rend pas compte le matin quand on ouvre
notre robinet mais le jour où il y a
plus d'eau qui coule on se dit que là il
y a il y a un gros souci
à une trentaine de kilomètres de là la
ressource se fait aussi rare
déjà touché par la sécheresse de l'été
le barrage de nos sacs a souffert de la
faiblesse des précipitations de
l'automne et de l'hiver
le niveau de ce bassin qui contribue
notamment à alimenter la Loire négotière
de sa capacité
les autorités françaises ont récemment
averti que l'état des nappes phréatiques
c'était dégradé même que dans
différentes régions leur niveau est
nettement inférieur par rapport à
l'année dernière un rappel que même à
cette période de l'année la sécheresse a
déjà des impacts à différents endroits à
travers le pays la petite ville d'Arlon
se trouve à une centaine de kilomètres
plus au nord là aussi les réserves se
sont épuisées ces derniers mois pendant
une dizaine de jours cet hiver une
partie de la population a été privée
d'eau potable février mars non j'ai
jamais connu ça moi j'ai jamais connu ça
on a connu ça sur les périodes d'etiages
qu'on appelle c'est à dire fin août
septembre voir début octobre mais jamais
en février on a vu une telle situation
en raison de la sécheresse la région est
aujourd'hui soumise à des restrictions
les fontaines publiques ont par exemple
été fermées
pourtant le réservoir d'Arlan et de
nouveau bien rempli mais le maire
préfère jouer de prudence difficile de
prévoir s'il tombera assez de pluie pour
éviter une autre pénurie habituellement
les printemps sont assez humides mais là
on ne sait pas quoi c'est c'est
l'incertitude des c'est pour ça qu'il
fallait qu'on prenne des mesures une
incertitude qui complique
particulièrement le quotidien des
agriculteurs comme Jean-Luc Bouchet en
ce moment environ 127 vaches produits du
lait pendant cette période chacune
d'entre elles doit consommer une
centaine de litres d'eau chaque jour dès
que l'arme des gros problèmes de réseau
d'alimentation on a des coupures d'eau
assez fréquentes
et c'est très compliqué on est obligé de
souvent de d'aller rabreuver enfin
d'aller remplir à la rivière pour
aborder les animaux en quête
d'alternative Jean-Luc Bouchet
entreprise de trouver le meilleur
endroit pour creuser un puits sur son
terrain pour lui il est clair que les
épisodes de sécheresse observaient ces
dernières années vont se répéter et
qu'il devra tenter de s'ajuster ça
penche beaucoup de questions mais les
solutions
on en a pas beaucoup non plus parce que
ça aussi bien que moi l'eau c'est la vie
ici Raphaël Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada près d'Arles